nous sommes peut-être à la veille d'une
découverte considérable en matière
médicale pour la première fois en effet
depuis longtemps le tabac n'est plus
mise en accusation mais au contraire en
effet des biologistes français des
chercheurs de l'inserm sont parvenus à
produire de l'hémoglobine à partir de
plants de tabac se produit sans risque
de contamination pour est en grande
partie se substituer au sang à
l'occasion des transfusions
jean daniel flaysakier daniel laisse
cette poudre noire ce sont des graines
de tabac et si on les plonge dans
l'azoté liquide si on les malaxe si on
les broie sont les cons qu'avant ce
mortier c'est pour en extraire de
l'hémoglobine
c'est le dernier exploit des biologistes
l'hémoglobine normalement on la trouve
pas n'importe où mais dans les globules
rouges
son rôle c'est d'accrocher l'oxygène
lorsque le sang passe près des poumons
c'est oxygène est ensuite libéré de
l'hémoglobine par les différents tissus
de l'organisme coeur et cerveau en
particulier
tout a commencé ici chez bio sème une
société de biotechnologie on a mis en
contact des plants de tabac et le gène
de l'hémoglobine humaine on a fait
pousser le tabac est au bout de quelques
mois n'y a plus eu qu'à récolter et
c'est à l'inserm qu'on a exprimé
purifier l'hémoglobine du tabac et elle
s'est révélée similaire à l'hémoglobine
humaine on devrait donc bientôt disposer
d'un produit de substitution du sens
utile dans nombre de situations
médicales
ce type de produit pourrait tout à fait
intéressant comme complément
thérapeutique à un certain nombre de
pathologies graves notamment la
pathologie d'urgence c'est vrai qu'en ce
qui concerne les accidents de la route
c'est vrai aussi pour les catastrophes
naturelles c'est vrai pour certains à
partir du myocarde ou certaines
hémiplégie
d'où l'intérêt de cette hémoglobine s'il
n'y a plus de globules rouges il n'y
aura plus de problème de compatibilité
de groupes sanguins et s'il n'y a plus
besoin de sang le risque de transmission
des virus disparaît